boy
well it was quite a night
we always just want it to be a good game
right yeah that's a game uh but we have
so much to talk about let's get into the
headlines
I'm begging you folks it's Monday and
wouldn't you know it it's week week
happy week week everybody you say that
and you didn't know what we were talking
about on this show you'd be like uh what
type of freaks
according to the makers of John Wick
this is Wick week okay John Wick 4 is
gonna going hard this week because
there's no other movie coming out this
week right right right yeah that makes a
lot well it isn't even coming out I mean
I'm excited for it this week but uh the
producers of John Wick have labeled this
week week every day they're gonna drop
hot Wick news right all over you uh
you're not even gonna see it coming
what present did we open on this Monday
of week week it's a poster on the first
day of week with the producers gave to
me
yeah it's just like there's no Villages
John Wick versus National Monument
versus the Eiffel Tower man's got a
sightsee lost his dog recovered it you
might you might have thought he was dead
after the end of the third movie but I
still alive and Now's the Time to
sightsee that's what you do when you do
enough experience you're off to grid for
real you dead dead you finally look for
your job you know you'll travel you go
City of Lights makes sense
um we we could talk a joke about John
Wick all day but we won't we'll save the
rest of week for week week shooting
tomorrow to see what happens
the Grand Canyon
but of course uh Ant-Man and the lost
quantumania does come out this week
which means we're getting the last
little bits of information before the
movie is finally here we don't want to
spoil too much
so we're gonna go as light as we can on
quantumania this week but just a little
bit of news and a profile about the
movie Paul Rudd spoke about a scene
where he acts with himself saying quote
there were all these different versions
there were so many other technical
considerations that took weeks to shoot
that entire sequence it was easily the
most challenging thing I've ever had to
do
got two things giving you two things one
we've seen this in the trailer the split
so this doesn't too spoilery but it is
gonna be really interesting to see what
I assume are going to be like a bevy of
variance and like how many survive all
these different things it's also
interesting because ants are one of the
few animals that are like Hive minded so
it'll be really interesting to see if
they have ant-man's behind-minded like
what if there's a bunch of Paul runs be
like you know marching in unison like
what if we get a bunch of Reds that are
like antler but I think koi I think
you're missing the most important thing
a lot of our viewers are wanting to talk
about the date Paul Rose mentioned that
hurts everyone he worked out the film
shirtless and none of the shirtless
scenes made oh all right Paul where I
mentioned that in an interview he said
he worked out hard to do the Marvel
thing at least he was like if this was
if this is if you know how does if this
is the last name and go around he films
a shirtless scene and it doesn't make it
I'm hurt for him I'm hurt for him
steroids okay worked out his ass off
just to show us his shoulders remember
that ladies and gentlemen they didn't
get we just saw arms yeah that's what
was it second thing in addition to I'm
wondering if that Ant-Man mentality is
is part of the is the the idea behind it
I'm also wondering if there's going to
be different variants that aren't Paul
Rudd and have you seen the clip of him
and his son at the Super Bowl no his son
speaks Leslie is him has a little phone
there's a little there's a little rud I
want to see one of them as a very name
okay
because we've seen Scott press push
through time remember so we've seen old
Scott yep we've seen baby Skies you know
so we could see all these very character
that we've really had to go that way
through time we've had them be plucked
through time but we haven't had a
character be pushed through time
themselves but I get what you're saying
yeah yeah when they became the time they
became the time so I'm curious if that's
an effect in quantumania we'll have to
find out uh this week and of course
first this is uh a man who watched
Quantum launch week so be sure to check
out nerd riot.shop we've been working
closely with our merch Partners to bring
you a whole line of awesome Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum any inspired merch I
got one of the shirts right here darling
this is quantum Thief run into a team uh
but there's shirts based on Ken your
shirt's based on the WASP uh there's a
stature Stinger shirt we don't know what
they're gonna call it uh is that true
there's a hoodie all this awesome stuff
and go to nerd riot.shop because we
recently launched our new meme mugs we
got two new meme mugs folks our most
popular popular and kneelable thumbnails
are now available as mugs you can drink
out of or eat at them I know some people
like to eat their ice cream out of a mug
you could do that uh head on over to
nerdrive.shop get yourself a meme mug
does he know do you have a friend who
doesn't know the channel at all but is
big on Sports Twitter this will blow
their minds This Will Blow their mind uh
so be sure to check it check that out
nerdrive.shop tons of awesome merch also
new Rockstar much support to Channel all
that great stuff do that but of course
with Ant-Man the Lost Quantum Mania
coming out this week everyone's been
interviewing Jonathan Majors why
wouldn't you he also has Creed Three on
the right yes very soon uh Jonathan
majors has put the call out for Robert
Tenney Jr to return as Iron Man I mean
we've all been saying it right we know
they're going to break that glass
eventually in the MCU uh Majors credits
RDJ for uh a lot of the good work in the
movie he said I would love to be across
from him on screen to see how our
philosophies acting wise and
character-wise just personally match up
his portrayal of Iron Man is so
fascinating and he represents a very
clear world view and energy of the
Avengers and I think Kang represents a
different era I have a small problem
and and hear me out gentlemen and
everyone watching I know we want to see
Tony Stark Robert Downey Jr again right
I know that we have the Multiverse we
can do variants to come back but at what
point do we allow these characters to
die and move forward with the story I
don't think they should ever bring Chris
Evans or Danny Jr back you see what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying let them
go it would eliminate all of the beauty
of the perfect 3x structure those
characters had and it would negate the
impact of endgame exactly I feel you
I think Majors were speaking on behalf
of like either uh Kang Dynasty or secret
War regardless regardless if I see those
actors as those characters I get that
conceptually okay they're a different
one but I will always go like he's back
and it'll heal just like in the comics
when someone comes back yeah so now
we're rewriting the story we're just
we're we're retconning it real quick I
understand we would love to see it one
more time
right it is it's inevitable of course
I'll cheer I'll be mad but the problem
becomes now we open this Pandora's Box
yes we say Multiverse when we talk about
Marvel DC and elseworlds or whatever and
we have this Pandora's box of now where
it's like you can't let the person go
now right because now anything that can
happen there's always this well you know
they brought them back before a perfect
example is Quicksilver yes boner came
back and we all were like that's
Quicksilver and even though we were then
explained to it it was still like that's
quick that's quick like you can't un
learn and unsee and I just worry that
like the way it ended was so beautiful
and so poignant and it was like the
sacrifice and Steve finally getting to
stop fighting that even if we see him
like as another Steve I don't know and
like Downey I also as a man I want Downy
to be able to like make stuff and I just
worry that like he hasn't escaped the
Iron Man Shadow yet and like and that
will only make like I'm very excited to
see him in Oppenheimer but if he comes
back in like two years later as Iron Man
will be like all right another five
another Hiatus he just all he does is
just toss that Arc Reactor to somebody's
catching and peace like today he did the
the John Favreau had his uh star yes and
Downey was there and he like came out in
a suit with like these awesome Nikes on
and immediately I'm like it's Iron Man
and I'm like I don't love that yeah like
eliminates his whole career people
Sherlock Holmes damn it you remember he
was a chaplain got an Oscar yeah I want
my third Sherlock Holmes film where is
that already guy Richie get on I want my
Multiverse chat no you didn't pop for
Doolittle you didn't pop up not quite
for me
[Music]
it's like a wrestling fan you know I
think we can all agree that a lot of
times wrestling is is bogged down by
Legends returning in other words he's
saying we're tired of seeing Brock
Lesnar versus every two every 17 years
old right now like we're right now
mentor
that's the thing that was like you bring
us and again that's the best analogy
right with a wrestler you just can't you
won't allow them down yeah you won't
allow the new generation that's like if
the Undertaker came back in raw 30 and
he was in the whole black and leather
jacket and everything you like oh Jesus
is he gonna be in WrestleMania but you
know you know he's like no I just did
this for a reason and even still but
when it comes to the MCU we as fans are
so conditioned to being like you can use
them again for this you can introduce a
person with that when you don't need to
you can let that actor and that
character go they can be referenced
there's one way I'd bring anything back
with Downey I would bring him back as
the AI that he programmed us into the
hat and that's Riri Williams's AI okay
because he literally already made it yes
and no one's more narcissistic than a
man that wants to stay around forever
but he's physically dead therefore it's
like I agree with I I said that a while
ago I got one Steve Rogers slowly as he
gets older if he comes back I want old
man Rogers and I want him to look like a
mix between Chris Evans and Stan Lee and
then it makes it cannon that every
Stanley Cameo with Steve Rogers watching
over his boys because we got him in that
scene in Age of Ultron with like the the
Navy yeah what if the Stanley cameos or
Steve Rogers traveling yeah how long do
we keep doing it oh no I'm saying to do
it once in 30 years you age up
and you make him look like you said
everybody
you make stand Steve and then it makes
it Cannon cameos
Steve Rogers Stanley Cameo it's insane
every time Stanley we've seen him it's
been Steve looking out for his people
what about what about when Stanley
interacts with uh Rob just wouldn't know
that that's him when he's older I don't
know what I'm gonna look like I'm like
70. that's true I hope
you can find some blooper stuff I know
what you're gonna look like when you
said it's a couple clicks away
on Facebook oh yeah we all had our
identities
ourselves wow we'll have to wait and see
maybe never come back who knows also
last Friday John Leguizamo shared that
he was almost cast as vulture in the
Spider-Man homecoming instead of Michael
Keaton he told comicbook.com that they
had negotiated and he was about to play
the vulture until Keaton's schedule
changed and quote wanted to roll back he
said that they offered him a small role
to which he refused I bet they offered
him that weird scorpion from one of the
scrappy people he was Matt he was
probably Matt gargan in prison it was
like yo I don't want to do this little
robot just show up one time also that
has not paid off yet for that actor no
that poor guy has not come back for the
Sinister Six they built without him
without him you know the guy from uh
Better Call Saul yeah he's nacho oh yeah
he's nacho he's not he's not a post
credit scene teasing the Scorpion like
they went as far as like he'll come back
and having a thing on his neck and
everything he was good I was excited for
that he was good in three lines just
like were you not not invested I mean
you just I get what you said but you
were like it was good I was like hey bro
it was a great we asked her for Scorpio
that's what I'm saying where is the
Oscar person Cameo uh speaker speaking
of Michael Keaton returning uh we get
we're gonna get to see him as Batman
again according to the Flash trailer we
also got uh a Batman poster along with
the other couple other character posters
there's of course uh a DH Michael Keaton
I can't get over it uh there's the Flash
and then I think they also did one of
Supergirl yes um
is amazing looking in this I'm just
gonna say it she is beautiful and the
way the shoot is just like it looks cool
it looks great even when you see her
coming out in the trailer of what you
think might be project Cadmus or
something else you're like she looks
badass yeah yeah even like the amazing
too yes it's better than the story
against the skirt but I I feel bad even
when they had even when they had um Tara
do it in the Supergirl Series yeah when
she went to the whole body it was
something different about that because
we know when they initially made
Supergirl why she had the cheerleader
type skirt we get it yeah and so yeah
people go well that's Canon that's
Canada and I'm like I understand but you
can modernize some things yeah and the
modernization is the full suit like her
cousins yeah it also makes sense if she
was in a military thing like trapped
shoot me in a skirt
yeah that's not the thing give me some
pants I'm cold up here it doesn't make
any sense for the skirt for this taking
the character we also saw uh in the
trailer you might notice there's there's
like lots of fence suits in the Batcave
oh man that gray and blue one no no no
this one I have a problem with this dude
here because this man went on either was
it was one of the social media sites yep
and his whole hope and dream ladies and
gentlemen can I get the camera please
his whole open dream it's just for bad
nipples that's all oh no no I said my
bat nipples were hard because of the
trailer Oh I thought you wanted no no I
got my bad nipples they were mine it was
a possession the possessive okay I
thought you wanted bad nipples on this
my suit was perky in my experience I was
saying the flash suit was so good okay I
was like I don't want to see oh no no I
don't want to see bad nipples again bad
nipples to experience that I don't want
to see bat nipples or bad butt cheeks I
don't care bring them back bring it back
uh Warner Brothers also put out a new
synopsis for the Flash Film which is
pretty interesting and it's long do you
want to get this boy if you if you wait
wait hold on that's how you do it
wind them up
flash speed world's collide in the flash
when Barry uses superpowers to travel
back in time in order to change the
events the past but when his attempt to
save his family inadvertently Alters the
future bear becomes trapped in a reality
in which general Zahn has returned
threatening Annihilation and are there
are no superheroes to turn to that's the
grammatically interesting that is unless
very conco is a very different Batman
out of retirement and rescue and
imprisoned Kryptonian albeit not the one
he's looking for ultimately to save the
world that he is in and return in the
future that he knows Barry's only hope
is to race for his life but will making
the ultimate sacrifice be enough to
reset the universe
that's how you wind them up and let them
go we got a prison break do you think
Batman's plan is to get arrested and go
to prison with a tattoo of the full
prison on his back so that they can
break out that way guys that ever watch
Prison Break yes
I know that's what I'm like yo I can't
see you guys about that show they would
break out and every year
that was that's just like Joker that's a
great pitch when they buy your show and
you're like oh I don't know what to do
yeah
what you like oh they out of jail so
what do we do put them back in jail but
that'll be the end of the show no no we
got we got more jails we gotta thank you
I uh I'm really impressed with the tone
they were able to do because there was a
really interesting moment where they
were shooting the Tim Burton Batman in a
very Tim Burton Way like the actual
cinematography yeah and then when they
cut to the bat flag it felt like Snyder
cinematography and then they went back
to flash and that's when you notice the
details because of the dichotomy of
musiadi style because mushietti uses
color in a really interesting way like
an IT and in mama and you wouldn't have
maybe seen the difference in his framing
with color if you hadn't seen the other
styles so I like that he's filming
almost multiversely it's like when
there's like a it's like jazz or a comic
Jazz where it's like there's a gathering
of artists where like maybe Andy Cooper
strong one bagley's drawing another and
it looks like all of those characters in
one frame but they're using their
different styles and I don't think I've
ever seen a crossover event where the
director was like let me pay homage to
the visual language of this character
for you and then the trailer was able to
do all of that while driving a very
interesting multiversal narrative in the
way that feels like it's going to trust
the audience like spider-verse did it's
not gonna like slowly feed you data it's
gonna be like we're diving into this
thing and I really was impressed that
they gave us a different take on bat
Fleck that looks a little younger but
also is Comic appropriate in a way that
doesn't take away from Keaton's like
it's a lot of cake and eat it too in one
trailer
I feel like the the bat the bat flag
with Ben Affleck's Batman it's the Bruce
that he knows in this moment I feel like
it's not uh too much younger it's an
older brooch because remember that's
what this is this is a 20 as we saw in
those this is a 20-year Bruce right yeah
this is a Bruce said I'll shoot you in
the face and don't care anymore so I
think this is that Bruce he knows right
when you get the Keaton Batman that
Bruce is probably the same I think
everything is parallel oh you think
they're both like 60. I think all of
this is running parallel but I I agree
it definitely is dope that you were like
musiadi was like yo I need to do the
Snyder style for this one I need to do
the Burton's outfits because if he did
one style it wouldn't there would be a a
field thing you'd Miss yeah yeah you
would have the scores you would have
those different scores but that look is
a big thing but I think all of these are
parallel because remember that's the
thing about the Multiverse right this is
parallel universes I think the only one
I do let me pull back a second
there may be a point where he does go
backwards
that's what I think that blue and gray
suit is yeah I think that's a young
moment in the group right yes yes that's
a young moment there that's beyond bad
flag yeah I think it's a younger bat for
like whether it's a flashback whether
it's a Time Distortion whether it's
because we also know the rules of this
world where they're going to have him
like charge up and have the power
displacement because in Flashpoint the
comic book He's a de-powered flash he
doesn't have powers in this universe and
it looks to me like that scene the
powers going through both of them like a
conduit so either maybe he's trying to
get his counterpart apart yeah or he's
like he has it and he's sharing it or
neither of them have it and they're
having to do creative stuff so I'm
really curious what the rules are are we
gonna have reverse flash are we gonna
have Zod be the big battle I love that
the trailer didn't spell out the version
of Flashpoint because comic fans know
what happens yeah we know yeah we also
don't know what they're going to choose
to do like Civil War very different in
the comic book I hope they don't well
one having Supergirl is already a great
way to distinguish this Multiverse
because arguably if you think about
thematically the Multiverse of the comic
to the animated is a Multiverse if you
think about it a live action is a
different Multiverse so we're already
living multiversely just by the nature
of having adaptation we currently live
in a Multiverse of these Concepts so I'm
really smart I mean I'm really smart I'm
really glad they chose to be smart and
do Supergirl because it allows there to
be a clear distinction between the
multiversal impact of these things now
when you bring up multiversal and you
bring up Powers at the same time the
ring is a very big teller yeah yeah the
ring is a very big teller because we
don't see the Snyder Ezra Miller the
Snyder Barry Allen with the ring that's
not that Barry Allen just has a suit
remember it's just a suit that Bruce
amped up and picks for right that's all
that Barry has in the suit now this one
there's a ring so somebody has to have
something or maybe what I don't think
Bruce is that Keen oh there's an origin
for that ring it's an economy they
already did it bethlehack is in a comic
Cannon there's three comics in the movie
that are out right now that they tease
at the end of the trailer to set up this
movies there's a prequel comic where Ben
Affleck's Batman gives them so Ben
Affleck made the Run yeah okay so but
it's cool because there's a comic cannon
that has came into the movies that's not
okay so a lot of people when they they
follow the comics to a team
to everybody
JLo Ezra just throwing up for sure I
don't know about all this conversation
I just like it in the trailer when
they're their feet touch that was cute
I like that it was like the Fusion Dance
the Dragon Ball Z yeah like the
lightning came out yeah what if our feet
touched under this odd ship
uh well we'll have to see how this all
goes uh I was just excited you know
we've heard a lot of talk about this
movie and I think the trailer didn't
disappoint it was exciting I'm still
interested uh we'll talk more about the
trailer someone tomorrow too uh uh and
also Eric's organized breakdown which
should be out any minute now I don't
know if it's on the channel yet already
who knows uh we should also talk about
we've got a lot of we had a lot of
interesting social media interaction
from James Gunn over the last few days
you know about you ever heard about this
he goes online uh he tweeted that there
will be feature-length DC animated
movies both inside and outside of the
DCU or of course they're gonna have
creatures command Creature Commandos
versus Justice League maybe or and then
we have like a Justice League versus uh
our RWBY movie
like an anime type movie okay I think
it's gonna be like an else worlds thing
obviously but I know we just left flash
this does relate uh and I don't know if
I'll be here tomorrow but if I am I'll
be lurking in that corner yelling flash
drive uh I do think there's an element
of
um allowance of Multiverse even in the
trailer that is gonna be really
interesting for what he's talking about
here because what he's saying is there's
going to be stuff that's in the main
timeline and there's also going to be
stuff that's not they could have Ezra's
flash stay in his mom's timeline and
then you've got your cake and eat it too
so you could come back and use Sasha
call you can come back and use Ezra
Miller so in five years tap back into
that Multiverse oh look Henry cavill's
back we sorted her stuff out without
even Kingdom coming in I think that's
why the Supergirl announcement is
announced I think of course gun has seen
the movie right so for those who haven't
heard if you know people who work in
this world like we do we all have
friends who've managed to see the film
and they've all literally said the film
is good that's been a consensus it's a
good movie that's probably why the
Supergirl movie was announced Sasha Kali
probably is getting that film
I wouldn't because there's no way there
was this big hype behind her being cast
in this role and everybody was like well
the controversy that is marred the film
in itself that will be the end of her
because we know this is pretty much
Keaton's last go-round we know this is
it I did this one last time I'm down in
the suit boom stop bringing me in for
these times
I did Birdman vulture just put my face
on some mother body that did it to Luke
Skywalker why do I gotta keep just a gen
at this point in the gym you don't even
need my eyes so I think Sasha collie
goes for it I think she gets pulled out
of this I think for this time being she
is our Superman I think she is because
remember the Superman we're getting from
gun that he's writing and he will direct
I don't think y'all know this yet he
hasn't announced it James Gunnison I
know he watches James is directing that
movie but he said it's a younger
Superman it's like mid-20s yeah he's
learning right this one has been here
that we can tell who the Super Girls
yeah Supergirl has been here well she is
the one that's been trapped and
imprisoned and all those that's what I'm
saying so what's under have you read the
one of them tomorrow it's quite
incredible okay so woman tomorrow is
basically telling the story of the
Supergirl that has been trapped on like
she grew up on a meteorite like she was
trapped alone nicely and she's at the
nurturing element of mom podcast
and that's all of Super Girls yeah but
this story in particular is really
interesting because she takes on this
orphan that was orphaned by this
horrible like space pirate and instead
of letting her strike Vengeance she
wants to shoulder the burden of murder
so she's willing to kill because she's
only had darkness in her life right so
she's a very hard and very edge very
like scene some stuff so it would be
interesting if we use the Supergirl from
this that has already seen some stuff
the one that is a little bit more on
edge like the Supergirl of Tom King's
run is and lean that way my only concern
would be that if you've got a Supergirl
that has that edge tour and a younger
Superman I don't know if they'll feel
familial in a way that feels like they
can share that kryptonite I think we
will be able to actually acknowledge the
Multiverse at this point I think gun is
going to acknowledge it I think gun
trusts the audience a lot I just know I
think he does the audiences I think he
does but I think he'll like not look
we'll say I'm from what you call Another
Universe this way I'm your cousin from
Another Universe I know about Krypton
all this other stuff that's what Carl
tells this younger clerk but they get to
go on their own paths and this car that
is more violent will fit ignis James
Gunn world yeah look at what we're
getting at this James grun world will be
her being violent will track all the way
through and she's not like merciless and
she's not cruel it's just really
interesting to have a Supergirl that's
like I wasn't raised with all this love
with this values and things like my
goodness is because I'm good not my
goodness because I was talking good
right so like I don't know I'm letting
the Nerds turn did they teach her
capitalism
she grew up on an asteroid meteorite not
until it crashes into a planet oh is
that a thing yeah in space look at the
bite look at the science being all these
inter-atmosphere and usually dissolve a
meteorite makes it all the way to the
ground so so they're into the media to
meteorite is the whether or not it hits
the ground yeah
learn something new that's cool
you can also tweeted and we kind of knew
this there will be a new actor playing
Batman in the DCU so it won't be
patented yeah necessarily it won't be
backflack be someone new lastly he
responded on Twitter that he would quote
sell or he responded to there was a
thing on Twitter people were asking
would you ever sell the Snyder purse to
Netflix you know they want something uh
uh he said I I have to say that has got
to be the wackiest hashtag ever since
the one Netflix hasn't expressed any
interest in that thank you although
we've discussed other stuff he said but
I just I hate the fact that look the
Snyder versus fans at some point are
going to have to just let go
they're going look I hate to say it this
way let go it's not happening like what
I mean it's done we're moving forward I
know everybody's like but Snyder didn't
get to finish his vision a lot of
directors don't unfortunately right
we've always said this he's working on a
new movie he's working on a new he got
his own Universe
let him have that go to that let the DC
Universe be what it is if you're a fan
of the characters I understand yes
you're a fan of the actors that were
playing the characters I understand but
again this is done it's moving forward
and to sit there and say well just sell
it to Netflix do you think
Netflix is going to drop close to a
billion dollars on something that is not
going to give them a return on
investment just so you can watch it yeah
you all keep sharing your passwords just
so you can watch it they're not going to
do this for you my new curiosity block
your passwords anymore yeah Snyder's
about Schneider one uh but I I'm curious
associate producer if they're gonna do
uh the Snyder verse if they keep it as
an else world if they keep it as a
Multiverse they could go back to it and
that's what's really interesting to me
is the fact that they are still
releasing Aquaman they are still
releasing Aquaman after flash either
does the ending that Pockets it or not
so you can very easily have a movie
where the Snyder verse is a Multiverse
because they might even make the
authority of Multiverse because in the
comic books wildstorm is an imprint of
DC yes it is from Wildcats as well and
the characters are commentaries on the
characters in DC like midnighters and
commentary in Batman Apollo's commentary
and Superman the fact that they're in
the world with them is very interesting
so I'm wondering if that's gonna be the
first multiversal in gun continuity
movie and that's probably gonna be the
most snydery movie like because it's
it's a darker edger are willing to kill
they're merciless they're they don't
listen to a nation like there's a lot
more of that mentality so they could use
the cider characters again but if those
movies don't do well because of all
these people like sell it but boy cat
mileage No One's Gonna keep making these
things but they're the vocal minority of
loud people but we also have that just
real quick and I'll say this we have to
establish what studio wants to invest in
this when you've shown the investment is
not getting a return and I hate to be
the bearer of bad news again for the 18
000 time yes everybody loves Zack
Snyder's Justice League when it dropped
on HBO Max yes it did incredible
streaming numbers but that was not why
HBO Max dropped it they didn't care
about streaming numbers they cared about
subscriptions which it did not rise at
all and so that is not going to change
going forward I think we're going to see
a really interesting hierarchy of power
between streaming and Theatrical we're
about to see a shift because there was
this weird experiment where for like
three years everybody was like okay
we're in a lockdown and we're gonna make
all our money off everyone's sharing a
20 the Super Service and no a 20 movie
ticket is a person a 20 a month shared
between your five family houses is not
so we have to shift back to an
exhibition level that is using the power
of Cinema not the power of everyone
sharing a living room so if you want to
make a 200 million dollar movie you're
never going to make a profit streaming
that's just not absolutely right exactly
and like I don't know how Netflix is
doing it I don't know how Netflix's
overhead works I'm just I commend them
thank you but I don't think we're gonna
live at a time where we can keep
expecting things like fan entitlement
has gotten to a point where there's
making stuff to get people to be quiet
and that is very unhealthy yes it's
you're getting scenes and parts of not
even just making stuff you're getting
stuff thrown into full movies that have
a story in itself that have their own
narrative that is like all right we hear
you on the internet here you go shut up
and that's what's happening now and it's
become a bet it's it's fan entitlement
in itself is terrible we do more stuff
like Wick week where it's like because
John Wick is its own thing you can make
it you can make whatever else
so Wick week more things uh finally to
run out the headlines uh we we gotta we
gotta mention this because this will if
you remember the beginning of this this
headline segment where we talked about
at the fast 10 Trailer Premiere fast 10
fast X if we decide what we're calling
it what they call it the event they
called it Fast Tax also I was this was
to variety I was right next to him when
he said this okay I'm so excited so at
the fast X Trailer Premiere when I asked
about his dream casting Vin Diesel also
put out the call to Robert Downey Jr he
wants him in the fast Saga saying the
down the line there's a character who is
the antithesis of Dom down the line
aren't we down the line
who's the antithesis of Tom who was
promoting Ai and driverless cars and a
philosophy that goes with uh that goes
with your freedom uh here's the bad news
for you Jay if they put Robert Downey Jr
in the fast he'll never diet no one dies
everyone comes back to life they got
operating rooms bringing people back to
life uh if you haven't seen already on
the channel Tommy and Whitney did a
great reaction slash breakdown to this
trailer uh Whitney knows so much about
the fast Universe uh that's do you know
Michelle Rodriguez Michelle Rodriguez
Robert nope Matt David and I wanted so
bad now she called out backwards as a
dad uh uh I want him to drive I want to
drive a station away
there's a bunch of guns in the back we
want to talk about this Guardians of the
Galaxy trailer but first we've got to
thank our sponsors this week and that of
course is nordvpn they're allowing us to
do our second ever break room Movie Club
uh we did it once before it's a lot of
fun we're gonna do it again this week
have you ever
question have you ever sat down to watch
a a movie or a TV show you were so
excited to watch wanted to find out it's
not streaming in your country you you
got to see it you're like it's not even
streaming anywhere I can't even watch it
forget about it okay all you got to do
is get nordvpn and with one click you're
able to set set it so that it looks like
you're in a different country right so
this week we want to do a movie we were
looking around what are we going to do
everyone loves The Last of Us right it's
a lot of fun we're looking out they're
zombie movies we're like oh let's watch
Zombieland Zombieland it's not on
Netflix here in the US uh it might be
somewhere else but I don't know I but I
got Netflix and I want to pay for
another streaming service because I
can't share my passwords anymore uh but
here's the good news folks you use
nordvian nordvpn boom bam boom you tell
you're in Japan it's streaming on
Netflix in Japan and you can watch
Zombieland don't worry it's still in
English you don't gotta read uh you can
still watch the movie in English so
that's what we're going to do this week
join us on Thursday here on the show
we're going to talk Zombieland we're
gonna because we don't want to talk
anymore Ant-Man that'll be Ant-Man day
we don't want to spoil anything so we're
gonna talk about Zombieland we're gonna
do a little Movie Club North have
nordvpn is so easy to use I use it all
the time they with one click you can
access one of their more than 5 400
servers in over 60 countries you find a
server near you for better speed or
connect to a far away location to freely
explore the internet they have great
speed on your PM it's not going to slow
down your stream you're not going to be
watching this in 720p folks don't worry
4K baby as long as you're paying for the
4K uh you'll get the high streaming
speed on North VPN it's the fastest VPN
out there you can use it on over 66
devices it's on every major platform
Windows Android iOS Mac OS Linux
whatever you want even your Android TV
supports nordvpn so do do like we're
gonna do watch Zombieland this week uh
if you don't have nordbeat VPN here's
what you can do you can grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com break room that's
nordvpn.com breakroom you'll get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift and this is completely risk
Thief risk free phone folks they got
nord's got a 30-day money-back guarantee
so check it out nordvpn.com break room
watch Zombieland join us on Thursday
we'll do a little segment we'll talk
about it you can put in your questions
all that great stuff it'll be a lot of
fun love that movie very excited
somebody excited to watch it again it's
been a long time since I've seen it the
zombie meta has changed a lot out there
let's see how it holds up with this
movie all right
folks we spent a lot of time on this
show today talking about anything but
the Guardians trailer but I want to talk
about the Guardians of the guys in the
trailer with you guys real fast uh
because I was really thinking about this
this bad boy okay the high evolutionary
all right uh Herbert Windham himself we
see him in the movie looking tough
looking angry looking scary uh any his
whole thing we hear this little line
from rocket right where where he's
talking about like he doesn't want to
make things perfect he just doesn't like
the way things are yes right but he was
saying he wants to make things perfect
so he's making this planet right they
roll up on it and they they tricked us
in the first trailer because we're like
oh they're back on Earth how fun this
isn't Earth
uh this is some sort of like planet with
anthropomorphic animals this is BoJack
Horseman come to life they better have a
Statue of Liberty some other animals yes
they better be with a lion yeah yeah I
want to see a little player of the Apes
action uh uh but it looks like Earth
right do we think do you think Herbert I
don't want to call him high Evolution I
only want to call him a Herbert window
because what a name do you think he made
this planet or is this a planet it so in
the comics right we have counter Earth
which he makes he puts it on the
opposite side of Earth's uh uh uh
rotation
the opposite of so Earth could never see
it I guess which I think is the cutest
thing ever uh what a cute plan uh but
then he makes that one over there but
then there's also in the comics there's
half world right where a lot of the
Animal Creations that he make they go to
like live there and he drops them off
there it's like a prison plan I don't
know I don't think we'll do both I think
it might be a hybrid yeah I think it's
gonna be a hybrid but I think it's
something he found I just for whatever
reason feel like that it's a lot of
explaining to make him create the planet
and the people so I think they're going
to combine those two concepts and it's
going to be like a planet that's
habitable I think his backstory may have
him be some type of scientist from Earth
yeah he might be from Earth because
that's why everything looks again rocket
tells you he wants things to be perfect
he didn't think Earth was perfect when
he left right right but he thinks you
know he doesn't want he doesn't like
what it looked like he wants to be
perfect he wants to fix what he saw so
that's why everything's look like looks
like what he saw in that time when he
last left Earth he doesn't know what it
looks like currently right so now he's
taking his technology he's probably
picked up some stuff along the way being
dropped off there now he can experiment
on the animals and just further improve
on what the creatures from half world
are so what I'm hoping with that because
I agree I think it's it's the way he
sees earth right but we have this
currently we human beings especially
Americans have this whole thing about
the better time we lived in and like
things are you know rough right now but
things have been better and worse and
high and low I'd be interesting if they
have a commentary on Star-Lord going
back to what he considers Peak and like
seeing the 80s and 90s and then you
realize that like no no I'm happier with
the people that I've made my found
family because if you look at like this
this certain group of people in this
country that love the 50s they don't
realize some of the things that were
wrong it'd be interesting to have a
villain that had that kind of mentality
of like this is the way things were and
I wear a red hat and then the people
that are like you know evolving and the
high evolutionary being a non-evolved
person so like Star-Lord realizing that
we're gonna use the word involved okay
I'm saying Star-Lord being involved I'm
saying no no no no no no no no no I know
yeah yeah so like a character that
basically sees evil solution as finding
your family finding the people that love
you versus someone that's stuck in the
past that believes that things should be
this way because that's good and it'd be
cool to see that character I want
Herbert Williams from South Central L.A
doing the watch riots he got snatched up
died and that's what he wants to be
better would you have a shot of like uh
you can kind of see we'll call it count
on Earth halfway I don't know what
they're gonna call it in this but the
Earth looking planet right when uh we
see Gamora on there and she's like kind
of carrying rocket so maybe rocket went
back to this place maybe if it's to find
uh uh Lila Layla uh and you can kind of
see like yeah the cars are they're very
uh late 80s early 90s the clothes are
kind of that way uh so yeah it I love
that parallel of like this is also the
time when that Peter knows most right
where it's like looks like yeah and yeah
in the comics right Herbert is he's an
Earthling uh uh he he usually is in like
Mount Wonder gore that's where he was
initially doing his stuff before he went
off into space right it will be
interesting to see how they established
that here because we do get a little bit
of a flashback look at my mer My Man
Windham he's this is him with his hair
that's a 1980s black man he's still got
his full head right his face is
he's wearing a very similar uniform to
what we see later yeah it's kind of a
shiny little thing yeah how did he get
off Earth does you think he was snatched
away or was he smart enough to get off
the planet and then remake the planet
somewhere else they tied into ego they
tied into the abduction they tied in
what Star Lord went through isn't one of
those characters that's the you know the
other side the end of the Yang of
Star-Lord remember though the cree have
been here right that's one thing we
always forget about oh yeah
in the comics it's the Inhumans that
show him like the technology the cree
would work perfect because we're we've
gotten rid of in humans there's the last
movie before the marbles too it's crazy
scroll Wars around the corner bases
coming up
[Applause]
please should have already been out
whenever that means remember everywhere
we're finally we're finally getting the
even kill from the covert delays of
release yeah we're catching up but the
cree were here in the 80s and 90s and
that would be that time that'd be
interesting that would be the perfect
reason for him to understand they took
him he probably saw one of them you know
again his his interaction wasn't like
Furies right you know his actually
wasn't like uh law beers yeah it wasn't
like that but it was something like he's
a scientist there have they have a
science they can teach him and that's
always interesting when you see a
character that just went from South
Central by the way during the riots but
like a character that just wants a medal
because he sees that as an improvement
versus like what rocket went through
because he clearly made rocket it's
going to be my theory is rocket gets
sick or hurt and they can't do anything
they don't know how to fix it so they
have to go back to his creator even
though that's an evil person and Layla
is the one that helps him get there I
think it's like they're actually
pursuing high evolutionary and out the
other way around and then they get there
and realize what he's made and I think
there's gonna be that moment of like
shock that this planet is like this
isn't this picturesque oh yeah I'm home
it's not the Tim Burton like Wonderland
do you think rocket has some of the high
evolutionaries DNA in them
because remember rocket was just a baby
raccoon Now Rocket is actually smart and
Rocket can talk and everything Layla and
so can Layla uh like Herbert he used a
part of his DNA to make the human DNA to
give them the upright life to be able to
speak and things like that he stretched
the human DNA the human genome as far as
he can go to place it into other
creatures
it would make sense and it'd be
interesting to see how that manipulates
The Duality between Star-Lord having
alien DNA God DNA because we just found
out spoilers for Christmas special
that's been out for three months
revealed that I don't think it's a
coincidence that we're getting that
reveal before yeah
another child that's what I'm saying I
think that they mirror each other let me
tell you something I want to see Kurt
Russell would a sister with an afro from
the 60s he's not using Brandy to tease
her what song is he using to to like
love her down he's using something from
The Whispers The OJ's the Isaac he's
playing in between these like Jackie
Brown this is Jackie Brown It's like a
Jackie Brown soundtrack okay that's what
I need James good let me know if I'm
wrong I hope they bring Russell back
just for this I love the idea that like
in Spider-Man everything's Oscorp in the
Sony version Guardians it's like ego's
just busy
he's just making babies I'll throw I'll
throw one more potential way uh my boy
herb got off the planet okay we see a
shot now I brought up one degree
mountain right that's where he did a lot
of his stuff it was a shot in the
trailer of him sitting crisscross
applesauce floating in space which is
very special
when she's dreamwalking yeah she did a
little bit of that oh did our boy herb
was he a mountain climber in his his
spare time he found Wonder Gore Mountain
that was messing around and started
doing this and then got off Planet
somehow first of all I want to know how
he do to just go across my little legs
but if the dark holds like tied to
that'd be interesting to play with I
don't think they're good I don't think
James again was interested in all that
Razzmatazz but like that would be a fun
little parallel to get him out of there
even just mentioning one degree because
yeah comic fans a moment and enough of a
like he has a mysterious origin like
they don't have to go to the wrong pops
then it's like Wonder Gore is gone my
guy and he's like there's any portals
out some young adventures
you mentioned Wonder core Wanda backs
him off she destroyed that take care
probably not but I do love that this
whole idea right of like uh the parallel
of him and Peter I think will be
important yeah all this Rockets you know
rocket and Layla and like Peter and
Gamora are they you know their stories
parallel in interesting ways like being
with the one you love finding your way
back to them I have a theory I say to
myself I'm dropping my trailer reaction
later on the day all right so if you
remember in Infinity War before Thanos
took her they both said I love you in
Reverse he said she said I love you he
said it back there's something may
happen where she says he says I love you
to her and one of them is Don more than
likely I think will is dying okay
because I don't think it would be too
easy again and everybody keeps asking
why do you keep thinking these members
of the Guardians are dying because
you're going to move on this is the last
time with this right we know Drax is
gone yeah Dave Batista was like bro
whatever y'all did to Jennifer Lawrence
and X-Men dark Phoenix just do that with
my face and hands like he's gone there's
a possibility rocket is gone and Lila
becomes Rockets takes Rocket's place
quill is the next best to go I can see
quill and Gamora like going off in the
sunset going up or going up like either
way they're out there
two different ships
man I still can't hear that song they're
getting hurt but I I do think there's
gonna be a moment of like uh family you
can never go home again on earth right
and then they leave like I think there's
a cosmic home to them yeah so they're
going into the sunset could be really
beautiful to be like Earth isn't for me
anymore this counter Earth whatever they
call it isn't for me anymore and then
that Sunset moment feels like okay this
is our new family this is what we're
doing I just don't know if I want Gamora
250 first dates this thing and like fall
back in love with them because it's like
yeah
no I mean like Edge of Tomorrow didn't
work for me because like the entire
movie is genius in the restarting and
then I love the movie by the way it does
work for me in nine ten minutes all
right 95 perfect but that five percent
when they like just start Snogging at
the end like you just met this dude like
just a second ago in the trailer when
Gamora says you know everything you say
you sound like you like her and never
was like don't you put me in this yeah
she like don't do this and then he even
start quill starts to look at nebula
like
she just ripped off like the wakandan
plating is that what it looks like
underneath maybe or maybe whatever
whatever scientists we see in that one
little steel they did something they
fixed it up it gave it better technology
remember this whole arm is just robotic
no matter what so it might it doesn't
have to be wakandan and vibranium there
could be other equipment or the high
Evolution what if she got hurt and what
if she got hurt and Rockets like the
only person that could help you and he
doesn't want to deal with his words and
stuff and like they got to go fix her
because no one would be able to know the
Thanos mechanics also what if Thanos and
high evolutionary knew each other that's
that's a big question everybody's asked
what if all of these these bad guys they
have their own I hate to use the term a
Legion of Doom everyone knows of
everyone
they got you know business cards hey bro
hey bro hold on there's a cabal hey man
look I know this dude that does
experimental animals
yeah he's in South Central okay so look
it's a boy named Herbert
my boy what did I ask about that we do
want to thank some of our super Chatters
today uh Christian unpronounceable
reminding everyone to like this stream
don't forget to like And subscribe if
you haven't already uh Stephen heider
pointing out DC and gun have to knock it
out of the park most of us who just gave
up are coming back hopeful after seeing
Peacemaker I think I think it's gonna be
great uh I'm excited to see even these
next two films they're not guns
responsibility uh maybe Aquaman 3 will
come out before 2026 whatever now Blue
Beetle got my Blue Beetle Man Joe Mark's
saying uh donated because Coy makes me
so very very happy oh also Bucky Barnes
excited to see Jay back on the show it's
good to see you on the show Jay thank
you thank you thank you for having me uh
also Christian unpronounceable saying
something koi said was brilliant that
must be oh the Stanley Steve yeah
uh but yeah I'm very excited uh what you
guys missed from this what Super Bowl
trailer did we not get that you were
Blue Beetle oh you think um
the rules the rule of three trailers now
is a teaser trailer an official trailer
I'm gonna show everything in the movie
trailer and I'll show everything in a
movie trailer uh the final trailer I
really wanted The Little Mermaid trailer
because the 23 footage yeah a real
rejects all day no but I uh the thing I
did uh d23 was shocking that that movie
wowed me more than anything like for me
little mermaid footage was like prettier
than Avatar like it was stunning right
and we still didn't get the Ursula or
like flounder or any of those characters
so I thought this would be a great way
to be like and like we got a little
mermaid I was ready for all those angry
people in Middle America to turn their
table those over that's weird
they gave me black people singing the
national anthems two black quarterbacks
on black history Monday the black Little
Mermaid this ain't my murder if that's
something you see when you look at a
mermaid that's the house and you're like
wait there's a problem I wanted to see
something from the Marvels
but there's so much to tying these
things together I'm really curious if
the thing I haven't seen Ant-Man quants
Mania yet so I'm really curious if
there's anything that ties Kang into the
10 Rings because I think there is and
I'm really curious if the Bengal in the
Marvels is tied to those same things I'm
really curious if anything with the high
evolutionary is tied to that same magic
I'm really curious I haven't watched
previous episodes of this break room
I've been on it but it's literally tied
I've said it yeah yeah like those things
could be like phase five could be like
hey you thought we didn't know what
you're doing all those those little
bitty things are like that yeah it's act
two like people don't look at it as it's
a three-act structure four five six you
don't give away the tie-ins till act two
this is today or Friday starts act two
of Marvel with Ant-Man so it could just
start like dominoes falling together and
then Kang blow it all up with Secret
Wars because that's what I've been
saying on this show that is what Kang
wants Scott to get him the ten rings
cameo in the movie because why they're
both in San Francisco because we know
SEMA wants to do like uh but he said
he's working a ton he's one on the show
and we basically like have a lot of
shangshi coming so that would totally
make sense yeah everything is it's
Quantum technology again we all think
that everything is we think the Bengals
are Cree right right but we don't know
the connections the cree may have to
another king right and the Guardians
might because they like to have some
more Cosmic of an element so it would be
it'd be great to have Ant-Man bring his
Kang Guardians tie a little bit not too
much because I like that it separates
about family like the fast franchise and
then the Marvel's ground it back down
while being Cosmic because it's perfect
timing you have grounded Cosmic Cosmic
to like bring that all together
does the high evolutionary no King he's
probably heard of them I think there are
rumors they were similar shiny purple
they are very both very picturesque also
let me just say it they'd go ahead and
see each other on the street and do this
that's the designated black man nod hey
your brother with time hey we never late
right bro way to be the stereo shy
that's how you do it they know each
other confirmed possibly possibly uh
well I want to thank you both for being
here today thank you for coming in uh
thank you all for tuning in today uh we
hope you have a great rest of your
Monday be sure to like And subscribe if
you haven't already uh join us here
tomorrow at the same time we'll be
talking more stuff uh from the Super
Bowl and all there'll probably be lots
more news tomorrow and it'll be another
day of this great week
I can't wait to see what we get tomorrow
uh check it on the channel uh Eric's
breakdown of The Flash trailer will be
up any minute now if it's not already up
uh and tomorrow have this breakdown of
the Guardians of the Galaxy trailer so
be on the lookout for that uh we thank
you guys for joining have a great rest
of your day let us get yes uh we'll see
you
[Music]
foreign